it's Friday and that means it's time for
Friday Foles for that we turn to Fox
News contributor Raymond aroyo all right
Raymond Biden hosted heads of state
today and it was called the America's
Summit that's right Laura look Biden
hosted officials from 11 countries
Across the Western Hemisphere they were
discussing migration and infrastructure
but apparently everyone has gotten the
memo that Joe Biden enjoys his time off
and days at the beach this is the
president of the Dominican Republic Mr
President we look forward to welcoming
you soon to the Dominican Republic at
the next at the next Summit of the
Americans in
2025 and that Summit will be in punana
so you have time to be on the
beach thank you very
much La it's funny but it's not funny
it's a glaring sign at a moment of
global crisis that the US is neither
respected nor feared and this is a man
Joe Biden he spent 40% of his presidency
on vacation and the world knows it
Raymond at least at least in pakana they
have all those all-inclusive resorts so
you know Joe can you know have have his
food and you know all of that was just
all in one price so son doesn't have to
kick him any more money after spending
the day in Maine with the the with the
Middle East on the brink of war and a
border crisis Joe and Jill Biden are now
on their way to reoboth beach for the
weekend that was just announced so true
to form true to
form no well these people I mean they
are pretty unbelievable but they're kind
of predictable at the same time Raymond
because well I think I have to Grant you
three wishes oh three wishes thank you
okay Laura yeah this week the White
House sent their om director shalanda
young out to pitch their bloated
supplemental budget my first wish is
that the White House would add a few
bucks to that budget for laundry
services hey shelanda hi can you tell us
about the domestic supplemental funding
that the White House has sent to
Congress absolutely now Laura the White
House posted this video of their OMB
director why is she wearing a t-shirt
with a big stain you see the stain there
and sweatpants I mean is this to add an
emotional layer of pity to their
supplemental pitch I I I don't know
quite what's happening here but the big
stain at least wear clothing that's
decent in the white
house I'm a throwback you know I was in
I'm really dating myself but I was in
the Reagan White House and you only wore
you only wore you know dresses skirts or
you know coat and tie it wasn't wasn't
casual Fridays ever well in the U Reagan
White House all right forget you know
forget the budget though Raymond what's
your second wish oh my second wish I
wish people would stop putting Halloween
candy out in bowls man your door and
hand it out I also wish people would
stop impersonating Bears to steal all
the Halloween candy the poor kids in
South Carolina South Florida look at
this this neighborhood they didn't have
any candy left because Smokey showed up
first Raymond that's a real bear that's
actually a bear well that's what
everybody said about that sun bear Bo
remember that zoo in China remember
everybody said that was a real bear too
no it was a guy in a bear suit so I'm
not buying it now maybe this is a real
bear but whether it's real or not it
shouldn't be stealing the candy and the
homeowner should answer it their own
damn door and and hand things to the
trick-or-treaters do they leave
Thanksgiving dinner out on the step for
relatives no you invite them in you
serve it that's how Halloween should
roll in some cases I think putting the
food at the door for certain in-laws for
different families across the country
they don't all get along so maybe that's
a way to give but not be present well
not in my house okay time for your third
third third and final way I wish Joe
Biden would learn the names of foreign
dignitaries and whether they are the
Pres Prim of pres pres anyway Canada is
joining the United States with funding
to launch the accelerator I think prime
minister do and
president and I think prime minister
trau and president
L are also so uh uh and I also thank
President Chavez uh for I want to thank
them Laura he doesn't know the name of
anyone at the table he's hosting a
summit of people he knows nothing of and
cannot even pronounce their names I mean
this is it it is it's funny but it's
tragic it's tragic and the world
understands what's
happening President Joe okay President
Joe I don't know who he's talking about
there all right Raymond thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else